I'm glad you guys were fun man I try to
do this joke this idea I try to work it
out last night twice and both times the
Indian audiences were like really like
really liberal like big feminists I'm
serious man it blew my mind I'm not
again I'm not knocking feminism you guys
be feminists if you want to it's just
when I was looking at that room I knew
in my head I was like most of y'all got
a [ __ ] doing your dishes right now how
am I the [ __ ] and you got a dish
[ __ ] you got dishes [ __ ] and I'm the
one that don't respect women I just
couldn't I was getting so mad and I was
like I know what the [ __ ] you do when
you go home you complain about my jokes
and then I got beat up driving Okita
career cambogia prettied up some girls
through the otega
and I'm the [ __ ] hate yeah I just
couldn't accept it from them let's be
consistent in your beliefs you didn't
want to accept it man I listen I get it
I know they're not slaves but like
they're not slaves yeah no gotta be
afraid man none of them are here they
couldn't afford it
why am I the [ __ ] I just again that's
the thing oh I hate oh hey oh it's a
comedy show man you got a laugh of stuff
that's fun to laugh at I can't just sit
here and say stuff everybody agrees with
that's a [ __ ] seminar who wants to do
that goddamn life coach I'm a comedian
yeah gotta be no none of that all right
you don't even have a [ __ ] woman here
to get mad at you that was a fun room
I'm gonna be honest I didn't understand
why it happened but I was happy it
happened that's like we're having fun
woo is like the teacher is gonna walk in
no teachers here all right they also
probably can't afford it